we haven't seen acting Legend Jack
Nicholson on screen in a while and just
looking more likely that we never will
again let's break down the latest reveal
about the actor's life that's got
everyone talking after appearing in
western tv shows soap operas and on
stage he made his film debut in 1958
playing the lead role in the lowbudget
Teen Movie the crybaby killer produced
by bovie impressario Roger Corman their
relationship led to a huge leap forward
for Nicholson's career in 19 67 Corman
tapped Nicholson to write the screenplay
for his psychedelic film the trip
starring Peter funder and Dennis Hopper
Corman said to flavor wire his career
wasn't really doing that much at that
time I knew he had experience with LSD
so I hired him as a writer corman's
Scrappy circle of actors and artists
were key players in the burgeoning
countercultural film movement and funder
Hopper and Nicholson reunited for the
hippie biker classic Easy Rider in 1969
Easy Rider follows two hippie Drifters
Billy and Wyatt as they make their way
VIA motorcycle from Los Angeles to New
Orleans along the way they encounter a
free love commune drugs and suspicious
towns folk they also meet Nicholson's
George Hansen an alcoholic ACLU lawyer
and self-described square it's George
Who articulates the film's US versus
their mentality
oh what you represent to them is freedom
after Easy Rider Jack Nicholson spent
the 1970s banging out some of the best
performance es of his or any actor's
career he rang in the 1980s with what
has become one of his best known films
The Shining in his book Stanley cubrick
and me 30 years at his side Kubrick's
longtime assistant amilio delandro
recalled the director explaining why he
was determined to cast Nicholson writing
you'll see everything about Jack is
perfect for this role his expression
even the way he walks he doesn't need
anything extra to play this part it's
all already there inside him Nicholson
took to the murderous Jack torren like a
fish to water kubri and dandro were
convinced of Nicholson's genius but upon
the release of The Shining in 1980
critics were less forgiving The
Washington Post lambasted the clownish
performance by Nicholson doing
impressions of the big bad wolf
Quasimodo and the films of Lon Cheney
even Stephen King criticized the
performance telling deadline the
character of Jack Torrance has no Arc in
that movie all he does this get crazier
in the movie there's no tragedy because
there's no real change time has been
kind to The Shining which is now
considered a horror Masterpiece and many
Publications have changed their tune
since
1980 even after Decades of achieving
critical Acclaim and accolades the 1990s
saw Jack Nicholson maintaining a soft
spot for be movie style horror and lower
budget films that appealed to younger
fans indeed an underrated Nicholson film
Tim Burton's 1996 satire Mars Attacks
recall some of the actor early
freewheeling Productions according to
Burton who was familiar with Nicholson
's cartoonish abilities from their time-
making Batman the actor was eager to
dive into Mars Attacks Burton told Arts
beat La in 1996 I remember that at first
Jack wanted to create a multi-roll tour
def Force performance when I asked him
which part he wanted to play he replied
how about all of them as a concession
Burton developed two parts for Nicholson
One opposite Glen Close the other
opposite Annette Benning although
Nicholson has left the door open for the
possibility of another big screen
appearance Nicholson's last feature film
role came in the 2010 romantic comedy
how do you know far from a commercial or
critical hit the film was widely panned
and bombed at the box office the result
was disappointing because Nicholson had
previously collaborated with writer
director and producer James L Brooks on
both Terms of Endearment and As Good As
It Gets each of those films earned
Nicholson and Oscar win clearly the
third time wasn't the charm for this
creative pairing Brooks hasn't written
or directed a feature film since how do
you know and Nicholson quietly made it
to swansong since then he's made a
couple of appearances in the spotlight
but never in a true acting capacity for
instance in 2015 Nicholson gave a short
presentational monologue as part of the
Saturday Night Live 40th anniversary
special in a 2013 interview with Vanity
Fair Nicholson said that he was not yet
retired but he admitted feeling less of
a drive to act however he told the
outlet the movie business is the
greatest business but I only want to do
films that move people films about
emotions people without question Jack
Nicholson is one of the most famous
actors in modern Hollywood his
distinctive snar and expressive face
made him an icon with one of the most
impressive resumés in the business
Nichol C has changed the face of Cinema
with roles in genre defining films like
The Shining Chinatown One Flew Over The
cookoo's Nest Batman A Few Good Men The
Departed and several more but as a years
march on it seems more and more likely
that Nicholson won't star in a film
again Nicholson is never officially
announced that he's done with acting
still it's been over a decade since the
star's last major role on the big screen
some recent reports indicate that we may
never see Nicholson in another film in a
November 2023 episode of his podcast WTF
Mark Maron briefly discussed Nicholson's
career with the actor's longtime friend
and famed record producer Lou Adler Jack
Stone he's doing whatever he really
wants to do yeah yeah yeah he wants to
be quiet yeah Adler added he wants to
eat what he wants he wants to live the
life he wants Marin then relay a story
suggesting that Nicholson truly is done
with acting saying a friend of mine
wanted to put him in a movie he had a
conversation with him but Jack says I
don't want to do it he goes you know
what I did today I sat under a tree and
I read a book laughing Adler responded
that sounds like Jack in all likelihood
Nicholson has played his last movie
character well that's a Bittersweet
thing to acknowledge for film fans it's
also more than fair Nicholson was in his
early 70s when he appeared and how do
you know that he's 86 now at some point
retirement calls to everyone but no
actor has left a more lasting mark on
the industry than he has with a whopping
12 Academy Award nut Nicholson is the
most Oscar nominated male actor in
history tied with Katherine hebburn for
second overall behind Merill stre
staggering 21 nominations his three wins
tie him with Daniel D Lewis stre Francis
mcdorman Walter Brennan and ingred
bugman all of whom share second place
behind he bur's four wins from the wild
detective movies and gangster flicks of
psychological dramas and romantic
comedies Nicholson has dabbled in almost
every genre of film of course not every
Nicholson film has been a home run the
1992 crime biopic Huffer was meant to be
a true star vehicle for Nicholson but it
landed mixed reviews and widespread
criticisms the 2003 comedy anger
management also fell flat but who knows
maybe he'll save his foral swan song for
one last Oscar grab Nicholson has often
been a controversial figure in his
personal life life and his career has
encompassed everything from instant
Classics to full-on flops but at this
point no one would fault him for
choosing to read a good book under the
trees over returning to the spotlight
what the hell's wrong with freedom then
that's what it's all about oh yeah
that's right that's what it's all about
all
right